[Music]
[Applause]
you can catch coach cower the rest of
the uh NFL today crew Sundays at noon
Eastern on CBS and Paramount good to see
you again coach let me uh let me start
with this do you enjoy seeing the
Patriots lose more or the Cowboys losing
more I see the theme with a Monday
morning I there were some great wins
yesterday let's not talk about those
let's go right into misery Monday yes
yes so do you care uh no you
know in a weird way Dan I've kind of
been there I I I I think when I look at
the the Cowboys you know it was um San
Francisco's a very good team um they
couldn't get on tracked early got behind
early you know you become onedimensional
against that defense it it's going to be
a long night and I think that there's
they can get things worked out I look at
New England to be quite honest with you
I I don't know where you go for answers
to be quite Frank I mean you look at the
offensive side of the ball namely a
playmaker um the quarterback is
struggling offensive line is not
creating any running holes defensively
you just lost your two best players in
Gonzalez and judon um you know it's it's
a big big challenge right now for Bill
you're coming off two very very tough
losses you know to be critical of your
team right now you could lose them um
there's a very fragile confidence I
think in that building probably a place
where Bill is not been before but you
know so it'll be interesting to see how
that unfolds can you watch a game as a
fan or do you have to watch it through
the lens of being a former coach um I
always looked at as a former coach I and
I get mindblown today by some of these
decisions in terms of analytics I mean I
watched yesterday John Harbaugh is a
good friend of mine a good coach in a
game where you know points are going to
be minimal in a very first quarter he's
got a chance to go up 13 nothing instead
he goes for it on fourth and one and
those three points were looking at him
the rest of the day and so I see it all
the time I mean what's wrong with taking
points um you work too hard to get down
there and I don't want to hear about
analytics because they tell you about
your odds they don't tell you about what
happens if you don't make it where you
stare at those things and you're staring
you in the face the rest of the game so
I watch it really as a coach to be
honest with you and I I look at it and
just seeing the ingame tweaks that every
coach has to make and willing to make
and how do you slow down a mind Miami um
offense that you know that looks like
they're playing faster than everybody
else we watched a little of that
blueprint with Buffalo and then you feel
for Buffalo they come off one of the
biggest wins of the year and they go
over there and lose maybe their best
defensive player in Milano they just
lost travius white sha mcder will figure
this out but that's a big blow for
Buffalo Bills how often would you send a
play in and the quarterback would change
it even though you didn't want like they
would defy you how often do you think
that happened in your career um I don't
know I I didn't I didn't call the plays
but I know when I would go to the
coordinator to call the plays I think
sometimes I realized the back thing the
one I got and I realized it was actually
um it was a maneuver they said they
couldn't
hear like like they would say their
helmet was out they're tapping their
ears I'm going like okay is that true or
not are you hearing me or is it is this
selective hearing so you know sometimes
you know but a lot plays we had you give
options to the quarterback and I think
the biggest thing you do to me Dan is
the quarterback earns the right to have
more input right so I think they earn
your trust and then they get learn to
trust you so I think when you go into a
game plans you're going against certain
things you can flip a running play from
one side to another based on what you're
seeing the front being you can also see
a front that takes you out a running
play to a passing play so those things
are always going to be there as part of
what you give a quarterback in terms of
game plan but then sometimes a
quarterback thinks he knows more and
then he just hits his helmet I got this
rothberger would do that um yes I find
that after the fact because I kept
thinking man we're having problems our
communication they're going coach
there's no problem I I can hear
everything in his helmet I go oh okay
let me look at the second alternative
here maybe was selective hearing I
wonder if with a quarterback of Ben's
size would you be using that uh the the
brotherly shove that Philadelphia is
using well he'd have to feel he have to
feel comfortable doing it right I I mean
I think it's so funny when you watch and
you think about a quarterback sneak we
think about Tom Brady who did it so well
for so many years he takes it and he
goes down low and it kind of hits his
head down and you watch Jaylen he's got
this you know at number one I don't know
if any centers can get as low as Kelsey
Kel's already a small guy he gets low
really low and it's almost like jaylen's
just riding the way it's like he's right
on top of it you don't see him go down
he's riding the wave of the back so it's
interesting to see the techniques
involved I don't like the play
personally I think it's a rugby play
it's a scrum um I think it's as bad for
football there's nothing strategical
about it but until we find ways of
losing of stopping it until we find ways
of people not getting hurt I know the
Giants tried it a year a week ago and
two guys got hurt so I think until
becomes a safety issue um you know
they're going to keep doing it um I
don't like to play personally it's no
you know but you have to stop it it's
it's been very very effective talking to
Bill Cower the Hall of Famer NFL today
on CBS analyst d said why don't we have
sort of a penthouse with the Hall of
Fame and I I propose if you have first
ballot Hall of Fame then can you do a
special floor for the uh first battle
Hall of Famers you know Joe Montana
whoever it might be a Dion uh do you
have any problem with
that yeah I mean I I I I guess I look at
it from the standpoint of you know I
think when you go to that lunch and I've
gone now for you know for two straight
years um um you sitting there and I met
this past year I met dick buckus for the
first time my lifetime Idol I think we
all recognize who there were some
quality players and coaches in there
that you know what they did was probably
more than what you did but yet I think
what you did was warrant of contribution
of being recognized as one of the best
at what you did um you know to sit there
and who's to measure what that criteria
is to put you into that other element of
it so I understand it you know I didn't
go in as a first ballot um maybe there's
circumstances that don't put you in
there for the first ballot I wasn't you
know there was a lot of media involved
with it I wasn't one of the most cordial
guys at press conferences at times um
you know and so at the same time I feel
very proud of the record that I had and
I I will match it with you know um a lot
of the people that are in there so um
you know and listen we all recognize
Dion Sanders first bout I think we all
know the first bout and you all know the
players that are in there but I I think
once you get in there to sit there and
say there's a first class and second
class I think it'll be a disservice to
the honor but is there a seating chart
though somewhere coach that might you
know the Hall of Fame events do they
have you know Montana up front and lt's
up front well I think they do it more by
whoever can walk
better A lot of times you go there
Denis there's a l if you can stand
you're in the back if you need to sit
you go in the front so
it's more by by your health status than
anything else how does every team pass
on Brock P seven times but he's going to
be and should be an MVP candidate this
year no question about it I know wrote
about it a year ago and we came in and
so ironic because it had me thinking
about Tom Brady right sixth round this
guy's seventh round and you walk into a
team and you sit behind a starting
quarterback it takes a starting
quarterback to get hurt to get your
chance just like a took um you know you
sit there and Brady Brady comes in and
um blo gets hurt and then all of a
sudden you know here comes Jimmy G and
all a sudden Pur comes in and you know
he walked into a great situation and I
think he just fits the system perfectly
he walked into a very good defense he
walked in a a c shanan offense that's
very quarterback friendly he he's very
very good at processing information
that's the thing I would take away from
Kyle's offense yes it's run oriented a
lot of motion probably a lot of dialogue
goes on a lot of moving pieces so you
have to be able to process a lot of
information very quickly now I think
that's the one thing you hear people
constantly talk about with Brock perie
is his ability go from one read to two
to three he sees the field he can
process things and if there was ever a
better offense to walk into it's
probably the Kyle Shanahan offense so um
yeah it's always interesting when you
see the free agents the seventh round
picks the sixth round picks you know
there's certain elements that you can't
measure going to the next level and um
Brock py has certainly surpassed you a
lot of the people that they thought they
saw and didn't thought his limitations
were uh they no longer are is there a
game that you just can't get out of your
head wakes you up at
night ah probably the
2001 AFC Championship game against the
New England Patriots um you know we
knocked Brady out we brought bledo in we
gave up a punt return for a touchdown
because all of a sudden we kicked the
ball from the left hash from our own
five yard line um we had a guy run out
of
bounds um Troy Edwards they replayed it
pushed us back they put the ball in the
right hash my punter Josh Miller kind of
didn't know what we're supposed to do I
supposed to kick it back into the
boundary do I go to the other boundary I
didn't know what he was talking about I
didn't even realize they moved the hash
he kicked it right down the middle Deion
Branch just took it right back for a
touchdown we go to kick a field goal
gets blocked for a touchdown we out we
out out had more almost 100 yards more
than they did um but yet we lost the
game um and that was a very very good
team in 2001 so I look at those
championship games and I think I think
about those um you know certainly the 95
uh 96 Super Bowl against the Dallas
Cowboys um so I think about more the the
the the games that ended my season not
the games during the season um than
anything else I probably remember the
losses more than I remember the wins
could you out smart
Brady can you ask smart Brady um no you
gota be patient against Brady um and you
got to just try to just if you can try
to create some degree of hesitation into
what he thinks you're doing almost like
in a weird way like Payton was pton and
Tom were so
cerebral that you had to play a little
bit of a chess game with them um and
then you had to take advantage of the
opportunities if he ever gave them to
you but if Tom Brady or pton Manning if
you showed them what you were doing from
a defensive standpoint they knew exactly
where to go with the ball and they were
patient enough to take what you gave
them so it's almost like who could be
more patient somehow come up with a
third down stop don't give them the big
play but you better be disguised in what
you're doing because if you give them
pre-nap information they're going to
beat you and just tear you
up is would you rather face that
quarterback or the the guy who
athletically is going to extend plays
drive you whoever that might be but that
guy that you just you won't have the
athleticism to counter yeah I mean I I I
momes is that guy now right Mahomes is
the the ultimate guy who can step up and
and talk about manipulating a pocket
having pocket presence he loves staying
in the pocket and you're going to get
off you know off scheduled plays you're
going to get his improvisation that he's
going to have at times those are
probably a little bit tougher to go
against to be quite honest with you
because you know those you can't control
at least the other things are
controllable I can control what I show
what I play I can control my disguise
part of it I can be patient and make the
play make the tackle but these plays
that get extended for six seven seconds
remember going against Michael Vic
that's the closest guy I could kind of
relate to Michael Vic is all a sudden
you can't rush as like you used to
always rush because you had to make sure
that you're very disciplined in your
Rush lanes and to tell a rusher to be
disciplined is kind of going against
it's almost like an adverse like oh be
disciplin but you want to rush your
quarterback like that's that's a contra
you know it's a contradictory statement
I know but it kind of you need to be
that way so you know you want Patrick
Mahomes to stay in the pocket and beat
you and he can do that but I'd much
rather stay in the pocket and beat me
then get out of the pocket and then
throw the ball down the field and then
you have the offenses right now that
today's the the biggest challenge you
would have is that Miami offense the
Motions the San Francisco motions Mike
McDaniel Kyle Shanahan it came from the
same system they like to give you a lot
of window dressing a lot of movement to
get you to kind of take your eyes off
where they need to be and they play very
fast and so there's a lot of speed down
in Miami that's a big Challenge and
again patience has to be a part of that
uh solution and try to at least slow
them down I watched that Steeler Ravens
game now granted it's the best rivalry
in football but that's bad football and
I I keep waiting for the Steeler that
Steeler offense uh where is it
coach it's a work in progress Dan oh boy
that's it's a work you're being
politically correct there no but it but
you know what and you just keep fueling
the fire by everyone sitting there
waiting for Mike Tomlin to fire Matt
Canada and to sit there and say you
can't do this and can't do that yes it's
going to have to be more productive yes
they're going to have to start taking
more shots down the field and they're
going to have to if they get Deontay
Johnson back maybe you get a guy who can
have a little bit of run after catch but
they're playing defense defense right
now maybe the best bookend rushers you
got right now High Smith and TJ watt um
they're not giving up the big plays and
right now Kenny picket is not turning it
over he's got like two two interceptions
in the last four games um you know they
blocked punt yesterday I know they kind
of gave it back and to be quite Frank
Baltimore did not play very well he had
six drops they missed a wide open
receiver Who falls on the turf at Hines
Field so you know it's a hin field the
the ghost of Hein field came out
yesterday for the Baltimore Ravens but
you know um I look at I I still like the
Baltimore Ravens and I mean I think that
I think Todd monin I think Lamar in that
system which more spread out in the
weapons that he has is at some point
going to get more and more uncomfortable
you see signs of it yesterday was not
one of them um and I think from
Pittsburgh standpoint it is a long year
and um in a work in progress because
clearly the offense is going to have to
be more productive than it has been
right now and I think getting back to
the running game is a little bit of that
answer and I would not just be with Naj
Harris the Naj Harris jayen Warren
combination Jaylen Warren came in and
really gave that team a spark when he
came in he made a couple big plays on
third down a couple big runs he gives
him a littleit that Splash a little bit
of that suddenness that you want to see
on that offense because you feel like
they're just plotting down they're
plotting on down you know just that 12
13 play drive you cannot live on that so
they needed Deontay Johnson's they
needed jayen Warren you're going to get
the the uh George Pickins maybe
one-on-one he'll make the big catch down
there but he's not gonna get the great
separation so I think it's still there
in the biggest thing they're doing is
they winning while keeping you know
winning games ugly and is it and that's
always gonna be a case with a Baltimore
Pittsburgh game when's the last time you
were in a fight a fight well ver
verbally or or
I mean I'm fighting with h with with
Boomer and Phil no no no that's I mean
like a physical a physical fight oh it's
well I would say
college no I actually got the fight when
was in the pros too I was just it was a
practice one time was actually the same
day at first time my my late wife I I
called at lunch and I found out she lost
our baby and um and I never forget we
went to on seven I was with the pads on
and I just was so mad and so I just
started crying and I just start hitting
everything and they're saying what go
relax relax I go don't you know I just I
got in a fight but did you eventually
tell your teammates and Coach what
happened yeah I did
wow I usually pretty good at control my
emotions to be quite honest with you
except for the time when you ran off the
after the first half weren't you didn't
you had a word for an
official well I I those were controlled
emotions I could have done
a oh I'm sorry you should be commended
for that oh well I I was
not those were controlled emotions I
like that okay we just didn't we just
didn't know that yes hey great to catch
up with you as always uh thanks for
joining us Coach man always a pleasure
you're the best I still got your you
know you gave me one of those jackets I
came I came to the Super Bowl the one
year yeah and I still have it I pull I
go oh here's my black Dan Patrick jacket
you I'm glad I'm giving you props as I
walk around thank you coach thank you
thank you that's uh coach coach cower
who knew that he was showing you know
restraint there he looks like a guy you
wouldn't want to mess with yes T that's
restraint stopping like pictures into
the pants of a referee as he wrote in
it's good stuff yeah good stuff